It's time to apply what you've learned
about markup techniques to the blog.
You can use the same blog you
were working on in lesson one, or
if you want, you can find a fresh
copy in the downloadable section.
At this point in the project,
your images are looking pretty good, but
there are a few opportunities
to use some markup techniques.
First of,
check out this random smiley face.
It's a PNG.
Just go ahead and
replace it with Unicode.
There's really no reason for
this to be a PNG.
And of course, what's a blog
without social media links?
Use Zocial to add some social media
links to the bottom of the page.
I'll be adding them to a footer tag, but
feel free to add them
however you'd like.
Also notice this weird flourish here?
It separates the main content
from the footer below it.
It's a PNG,
which is obviously pretty unnecessary,
so replace it with something
that does make sense.
In the solution,
you'll see me just totally remove it and
replace it with some more subtle CSS.
Here's an option for you.
Add a responsive logo.
Check the instructor notes if
you want some inspiration.
Once you have replaced this smiley
face with a unicode smiley face, and
once you've replaced the flourish
with something else using markup, and
once you've added some social media
icons, a code will appear on the page.
Type that code in here to continue.